foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
49ers NFL reporter for the San Jose
Mercury News cam Inman joins us now cam
thanks for joining us any update on
Brock Purdy's injury
and not yet he is getting an MRI today
just to figure out is it a UCL ligament
injury was it the ulnar nerve that
something flared up but I mean Dan like
four hours after the game he still had
pain shooting up you know up and down
from the elbow through the wrist and it
was why he couldn't throw I mean he did
you know he completed two passes got him
to Midfield and that then he got hurt
and then after that Josh Johnson came in
uh the offense wasn't run smoothly he
gets concussed two minutes after
halftime and then they had to put Brock
back in there but the forward pass was
gone from the Playbook and the Eagles
just stacked the box and there was
nothing that the Niners could do
offensively just it really became just
the dead of a game right I mean there
wasn't much going on
it almost felt like the Niners were
surprised at just how good the Eagles
were up front and and that's not fair to
the coaching staff but just watching it
um I don't know how you you know
simulate Hassan Reddick unless you know
you're using Bosa in practice but
um I I was surprised that the heat they
put on rock pretty early
well you know they had just played the
Cowboys and Micah Parsons and so they
kind of saw an athletic pass rusher yeah
but but when you match Hassan Redick up
with a backup tight end
um and that's the guy that he blew right
past to get to Purdy it looks like a
pretty bad play call but the play call
was uh Brock's got to take a seven step
drop give Brandon I need time to get
open and he was getting open but I mean
you go back and look it was about three
or four seconds and in the NFL that's an
eternity and it gives any speed pass
pressure a long time to get back there
so uh the the Eagles defensive front
though like you said I mean all across
the board pressure pressure pressure the
Niners knew that was coming I mean they
built their team on the same idea uh
it's just they couldn't get to Jalen
hurts and the the Eagles didn't have to
pass it once Purdy was out of the game
it was all right let's just run the
clock down and get out of here how would
you sum up this year for the Niners
oh my gosh I mean could you think of a
crazier year with the quarterbacks and
this is a franchise built on just like
that quarterback Saga year after year
but when Trey Lance goes down into the
home opener Jimmy Garoppolo who like was
in Camp thrown on a side field because
he was in Exile waiting to get traded he
comes back revises 49 a career the stock
shoots back up for Jimmy and then he
gets hurt so you're down to Mr
Irrelevant who uh just plays lights out
he had this Charmed Life and just
everything he did obviously he protected
the football up until yesterday but
Shanahan really kind of bought into him
and he trusted him at quarterback so
everything about the Niners Dan is
always about the quarterbacks no matter
what and no no year was like this one
but the fact that they made it to the
NFC championship game with a rookie
quarterback
um the NFL sack leader was Nick both so
he didn't have any sacks in the playoffs
so obviously the defense could have done
more but uh really I mean if you had
told me back in maybe the home opener
said oh this season might go off the
rails because Lance is gone and then
once Jimmy Garoppolo went down you're
like well there's never been a Super
Bowl reached by a rookie quarterback so
there's no way the Niners are going to
go deep they made it to this far kudos
to them great coaching job by Shanahan
but now they have a huge off season
again trying to figure out what's going
to go on a quarterback and like Circle
and back a lot of it could depend on
Brock Purdy's MRI results like how bad
is this elbow injury because they will
get Trey Lance back
um from his ankle issue but uh Jimmy
Garoppolo free agent he didn't get he
didn't get out of town this last summer
so maybe he doesn't he doesn't leave
again
if they had gotten to the Super Bowl
would Garoppolo been healthy enough to
to start for the Niners if Brock Purdy
couldn't play
I'd want to say yes but he they never
allowed him to practice yet Dan you know
he broke his foot on December 4th uh he
got back on the field to do some
individual conditioning running like a
week and a half ago so but they never
put him in a practice so everybody said
well the Niner should have had an
emergency QB ready to go Jimmy Garoppolo
was qb3 he wasn't active yesterday
um you know so it's like I guess if you
if you give them two weeks I would think
that he would have made a game but you
know Jimmy's a gamer he probably would
have wanted to do it but uh it wasn't a
great situation it's a what if there's a
lot of what-ifs out of yesterday all
right what if
uh Purdy has a serious injury and do you
open the door for Tom Brady or Aaron
Rodgers yes there it is that's the
that's the question that's going to be
asked every day and I mean it makes a
lot more sense now Dan than it did maybe
a year ago or even a couple years back
when there was talk of Brady going to
the Niners instead of the bucks but
Jimmy Garoppolo was coming off the Super
Bowl and he was still relatively young
and he had a great year
um this one there's so much doubt about
Purdy and then Lance I think you got to
reach out to Brady and see if he wants
to come back to the Bay I mean do you
remember when when I mean Brock Purdy's
first first start was against Tom Brady
and he beat him and then after that game
there was a reception line of Niners
going up to shake Brady's hand and get
him to sign uh autographs on the on the
intercept it was a it was a surreal
scene of like all these Fanboys came out
in the Niners they wanted Tom Brady so
do you think he'd be welcome absolutely
do I think Aaron Rodgers would be
welcome I do not I mean they loved
beating him in the playoffs year after
year and Aaron it's just it's a
different situation with Aaron he has to
get traded from the Packers they looked
into doing that a year or two ago it was
a no-go that's why I think Brady's
probably a better option
um but is he the best option it's uh or
do you keep Jimmy Garoppolo do you keep
Lance it's there's so much quarterback
questions coming and it's it's a typical
49er offseason but do the Niners know
what they have in Trey Lance
no I mean I don't think anybody does I
mean they have a better idea they know
how much he knows the Playbook but I
think they know a lot more about Brock
Purdy now don't you I mean Brock won
eight games uh Shanahan trusted him in
his offense and he opened it up a little
bit more and it just seemed to fit and
uh Brock was very well aware that he was
surrounded by a great sporting cast
um but at the same time yesterday
revealed that it really does take a
quarterback to win in the NFL or
somebody that can throw a forward pass
more than 10 yards cam thank you we
appreciate you getting up and uh sharing
your insights with us
my pleasure thanks Dan that's uh cam
Inman the Niners NFL reporter for San
Jose Mercury News